hey guys this is dad's defender thing
here and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of the season 4 premiere
of the walking dead televisions biggest
drama kicks off with 30 days without an
incident well accident accident is an
accident yeah yeah so you know we lead
reviewed you know last season's finale
and we were really disappointed so I
think a lot of people are really
interested in seeing how this this
episode plays out right what did you
think it's good episode it's solid you
know Scott's get Scott Gimple taking
over a showrunner from lemma zara and
you know he wrote the episode Nicotero
directed it it's good I mean I think
Walking Dead has become a walking dead
is and I don't mean to say that it's a
bad thing I think walking dead is just
it is what it is I don't think it's
gonna be necessarily thing amazing other
than anything bad it's just it is what
it is it's a solid episode again great
character i love the actors obviously
Rick you know is this the actors is
grave got some new characters yeah I'm
some a lot of new characters oh no I
mean it could we'll see what happens I
don't know what it would you think yeah
I think it's all is a good way to
describe it because there was nothing
amazing in episode but heads you know uh
some build up and set up for the right
of the season and we still don't know
what happened with the governor yeah we
see Michonne's kind of off like trying
to find I am laughs there's we didn't
see him you know you know Andrea is dead
no one mentioned really that in this
episode no yeah everybody's kind of got
a new life who got some we're laying any
relationships and stuff like you're
smiling yeah that's caliphate you the
whole time she's more likable man let's
start off with Rick Rick is still I
don't know he's probably know he's not
seeing dead people anymore no are still
a little off right when I should we pick
up the phone calling her anymore but
yeah he's in the woods by himself it
seems like Hershel is concerned about
him yeah you know he's going off in the
woods doesn't have a gun he's not
carrying a weapon on him in the woods
you know he's guys just got a little
hunting tools and yeah he's just kind of
off on his own so he stilled in a loner
thing we're not sure if he's still crazy
but he's still kind of doing the loner
thing is keeping his distance from
everybody's not fully invested in the
group
no you have Daryl now is kind of more
the leader of yeah he's an erect yeah
and people it's funny you know you had
that scene where the guys like I want to
shake her hand like a famous celebrity
or something like that I am Darrell you
know he's that I don't think he's used
to the love right now hmm it's weird and
he still got that we're relationship
going on with Carol cuz like I i I'd
rather than like I realized that it
probably realize they're not that far
apart in age butts like I rather than
just like either go all at it like be
boyfriend and girlfriend or like hook up
or like but they always like kind of
sneak in hint at like the last season's
okay let's go fool around or it's like
just can you just like either God's
weird is good that's I just they
probably are you know closer to the same
age than I think right but just the vibe
is just she seems more motherly yes it
who seems like a teenage boy right yeah
but he is you know bringing home the
goods getting the food right they have
this whole community thing I miss Susan
pigs now I'm assuming this is several
months later yeah how far along but
definitely in good enough time where
they've built this community and and
kind of like almost like a nice new gate
yeah everyone has their routines and
almost like chores that they have like
zombie cleaning it up and story time
yeah which is actually knife training
time but you know um so speaking of new
characters we you know we had a few new
ones I mean one that that died went away
yeah we law yeah we did you have a bad
boyfriend who yeah for about like five
minutes is he dead okay okay I don't cry
anymore I don't cry anymore I'm tough
I'm a tough chick now I don't cry
anymore no it's just uh I did like that
I mean I like that she didn't get all
saw before me this is a boy that I'm has
been that long but I'm sure they have
been dating that long so and she's tough
now I mean she doesn't you know they're
people die if you lived in this world
people are gonna die he's got to be
prepared for that and then he have a we
mentioned kerry condon that's his name
she um rome and luck and she plays that
the girl that Rick finds in the woods
that tries to kill him yeah we don't
know now this is the question we need to
ask do you think underneath that that
blanket is it a head or the baby I
thought it was like a zombie babe
dominating or
who's all like kind of some motion was
in I don't know they breathe but you
know wonder what was underneath the line
and guessing it's a zombie head at first
I thought it was a zombie baby and I
thought like she was like trying to kill
people and things as possible to feed
the zombie baby but now I think maybe
it's more about the head yeah weird
really weird I've got that Rick I'm glad
that I kind of left it a little bit of a
ambiguous a little bit of a mystery
instead of Rick going he was colored
eyes like okay I'm getting out of here
I'm not gonna touch this is crazy he's
got enough drama in his life right now
and then he revealed the three questions
yeah yeah I like the three questions uh
how many walkers have you killed how
many people have you killed and why i
like that that's that's good trying to
get I guess gage character the best you
can know how that's gonna that's a
foolproof system and then the other
character who is also another HBO actor
he played a D'Angelo Barksdale in the
wire offices yeah you went on the the
the kind of the run to the store which
apparently there was a lot of alcohol in
there I thought maybe was a memo oh yeah
the long haul store um it was like a big
spots or not big lies but thanks yeah I
like that like we finally see the
helicopter where land which is little
different in the comic books in the
comic book they find the helicopter
before they actually even meet before
they even meet the governor a little
different but it's fine it doesn't
matter it's kind of a it was a cool set
up the helicopter weighing down the
building and the zombies falling through
that was actually one of the better
action sequences on the show I thought
that was pretty cool Glenn was all
suited up with your armor tactical all
right you know like he is a SWAT team
member when the way they shot of the way
Nicotero decided to shoot it I like how
they showed like how all the flat screen
TVs and blenders everything in it
requires electricity has been left
behind because they're pointless they're
pointless useless right you don't even
wine is on the shelves I mean wine you
know you can drink wine is good but I
mean you know you need to hydrate you
need I mean I like I like how they
showed all those different scenes on
school tyreese's sisters like Michonne
part 2 or something cuz you're like ran
out everybody's gonna read the sword
doing all kind of an action so I wonder
how that's gonna play out is good but
like I see all these new characters I'm
looking at these little kids you know
like story time like my name is AMA
like you're all gonna die probably yeah
yeah I can't keep it so many people on
the show so I mean it's good i mean i
like that i think this could breathe
some new life in the show i think we
need some new characters even though the
character that we have our great after
Andrea died I think we need some people
to fill those holes so it'll be as she
to C household community how long it
lasts I don't know yeah and also is the
governor still going to be the villain
of the season right and when is he gonna
come back I mean he's definitely gonna
come into play somewhat because
otherwise they would have killed him at
the end of last season right right but
since we know that he's still alive
there's he's gonna be brought back for a
reason but yeah the question is is it
going to be as the main villain again or
we're gonna see someone new and to ask
just I guess I put this out to the thing
that I think your community what was the
significance I was still trying to
figure out the with it usually the
intros have significance to him Rick dug
up a found a gun an old gun he was also
sharing this zombie throughout the whole
episode that had these weird creepy eyes
or no Isaac can't remember what is the
significance you know i mean it see I
haven't watched every episode over and
over again so I can't member that with
that is that gun was that used on a
significant seen in a previous serie our
previous season like a curious I don't
know anyway has a new information is
that the one Carl used to shoot his mom
right was that right was the white Carl
used to shoot that person yeah in the
you know what a zombie the guy in the
verizon finale yeah I couldn't remember
no I mean overall I liked the episode
he's good it wasn't anything that blew
my mind but I enjoyed it it's just it's
the question is is how much longer can
the walking dead stretch that's my thing
I think people a lot of people get
really ugly little of the show I
understand it is a good show it's got
great actors good action it's shotwell
directions great but story wise i'm not
sure where else it can go like what more
emotion like how many were people who
died see brutally killed and how many
loved ones we have to see loss like
what's the show's purpose that's i think
with the walkie dad needs to think about
is where does it want to go from here Oh
another reveal we had was that Maggie
wasn't pregnant yeah like we had thought
that she was in the season finale and
now I don't know if they had planned on
this or they just decided let's not go
down this route you know in this
storyline he's like oh thank goodness
yes no pregnancy yeah yeah kid and and
yeah he's relieved where she was like I
I would have minded you know it's like
we can have one still maybe uh it's not
an easy place to raise a baby no not
another mouth to feed it's you know
someone that you have to protect plus
they already have one yep with Rick's
baby Ricky Laurie's baby well maybe it's
Rick's baby yeah like the in like the
the the farm in season two we gotta
wonder how long are they gonna stay in
the prison it's gonna last the whole
season they gotta get overrun you know
who knows like we're gonna be by the end
of the end of the season I'm hoping that
I'm here so they're go somewhere else
because otherwise you might as well
it'll just be a community like that's it
that's like the end of the show like
okay they live not happily ever after
but like they they can survive at this
prison right and that's another thing I
think just looking ahead after you don't
you know into the end of this review
here and just we know the showrunners
are the studio the guy do a spin-off we
know that's probably going to happen
they want to do is spin off they said
they'd love this show to go on as long
as possible Kirkman is not going to stop
right in that comic book so it's again
that's not a bad thing like I like
seasons but again we've talked with us
in several other shows we reviewed how
many seasons how many shows do you know
where they're strongest seasons or seven
and eight really i mean the strongest
ease is usually maybe two three four
five baby and then that's when they hit
their peak and most series don't peek at
season eight yeah so worries me that i
hope they have an endgame I love God the
show's making money for AMC that's
awesome but it's like I don't want them
to overdo it just milk it you know yeah
become a victim of their own success
like we've seen with soprano some other
years like lost boss something like that
and I'm hoping to that this spinoff I'm
interested in just because it's going to
take place in a whole different area
right and maybe the situation is
different there that's what they can't
just make a Walking Dead part two oh
yeah alright guys so that's what we
thought of the season premiere of
walking dead you can post your comments
below on the website or on our YouTube
channel make sure you subscribe to its a
think hero prom we're also on Twitter
you come chat with us wanna go ciao
Dennis and I you know are both
at think hero personally i'm at griffin
de and we also have a Facebook page that
facebook.com slash sneaky row fans
you